at the start I'd just like to reiterate
Donald Trump's laudable interruption of
his now four day long
temper filibuster to offer his
now-famous public service announcement
made at Panama City Florida about the
importance of voting YES so go and
register make sure you get out and vote
November 28th in fact I'll go further if
you're voting on November 28th I say
vote for Donald Trump what the hell is
wrong with this guy November 20th is
cyber monday the online Christmas
shopping apex November 28th quick a
diversion maybe Trump could attack a
prominent Republican like Mike Pence
maybe Trump could say Bill Clinton had
an affair with Nancy O'Dell
maybe Trump could claim that he's being
appalled by that tape on which Hillary
Clinton is heard using coarse sexual
language about women and a conversation
with Billy Bush because those are about
all that we're missing from the Trump
meltdown that began early Monday
afternoon
there have been Trump tweet storms
before and Trump rages before and even
Trump attacks on other Republicans
before but this one has taken on a kind
of mr. Smith's evil twin goes to
Washington quality it has gone deeper
and deeper into a kind of campaign
psychosis and yet it is being treated as
if it were some kind of campaign
strategy Donald Trump's new attack
strategy curbed Clinton vote wrote The
Wall Street Journal late Tuesday Trump
plans to renew the nationalist themes
that build his base and amplify his
no-holds-barred attacks against Hillary
Clinton who tried to depress Democratic
voter turnout his advisors said so it's
full-on no holds bar absolute war
against Hillary Clinton throw anything
at her use any means by hook or by crook
just keep pounding away that she's the
worst person in history and all efforts
must begin with the understanding that
she is the source of every evil in the
world and not only is nothing and no one
more deadly than her but that nothing
and no one ever could be under any
circumstances disloyal ours are far more
difficult than crooked Hillary they come
at you from all sides they don't know
how to win I will teach them so how does
that work if you read that and you're a
you know Trump voter you think Trump
says Hillary is bad but Paul Ryan is
worse but if you read that in your you
know
hillarie voter you think Trump says
Hillary's bad but Paul Ryan is worse
only one kind of voter could read that
and not think Trump says Hillary's bad
but Paul Ryan is worse that would be the
voters who actually are Donald Trump
quick a diversion the very foul-mouthed
Senator John McCain begged for my
support during primary I gave he won
then dropped me over locker room remarks
once again locker room remarks because
everybody talks that way in their locker
room and everybody's locker room is a
bus on a Hollywood film lot in which all
the men are wearing microphones and they
know they're being videotaped for a
television show so that didn't work
against McCain quick a diversion he
torched McCain again then said I
wouldn't want to be in a foxhole with a
lot of these people but I can tell you
that def bit of strategy reminded
anybody still listening that he would
never have been the in a foxhole with
John McCain because while McCain was a
pilot who was tortured inside a North
Vietnamese Bo w camp at exactly the same
time Trump was getting draft deferments
for a hangnail or whatever that was
quick a diversion that crazy wandering
stuff during the debate Tuesday night
quote she came into my territory I never
walked near her she stands right in
front of me yesterday NBC reported that
as all this was happening to big-money
Trump donors tens of thousands of
dollars had asked for their
contributions back and the bundler who
gathered that money and about a million
in total says he's done raising money
for Trump quick a diversion back to the
Greatest Hits and late Tuesday he stands
up in front of a rally and blows that
dog whistle again Hillary Clinton wants
to dismantle our Second Amendment so
maybe she should start with her security
people not carrying weapons mr. Trump I
don't know if you've noticed this but I
don't like you I think you're the most
dangerous political figure in our
country's history although on sunny days
I begin to think you're only the most
dangerous political figure since the
1864 Democratic presidential nominee who
ran on the platform of moving up on the
civil war repudiating the Emancipation
Proclamation so politically I don't care
if you melt in the hot Sun
but personally all human life matters to
me so let me say this just on a basic
ask Not For Whom the Bell Tolls level
get some help see a doctor do submit a
ssin take a brief leave of absence read
a book on ten quick steps to a healthier
mind through something this is not
innovative brilliance this is not
campaigning missus not self-advocacy and
there is no brand new political strategy
by which one wins by getting fewer votes
get some help
I will even on the premise of it tolls
for thee
offer you a little cover here when you
said make sure you get out and vote
November 28th you were referring to the
campaigns for mayor city alderman
Township Supervisor and Township
Assessor of Bloomington Illinois because
November 28th is the deadline there for
filing petitions to run for those
offices that's what you meant your tolls
for thee
that's the closer I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space